[Applause]
terrified
but alive reunited with her father
a miracle amid so much misery
children among those killed in the
highest single day of death in gaza
during a week of israeli air strikes
israel
says palestinian militants are the
target but
on the other side of the border more
hamas rockets fired towards israel
many blasted out of the sky over the
seaside city of ashkelon
very exciting so is your house damaged
in my house
just a glass a little
becomes a boom not not a
inside just
[Music]
she races for cover
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
four sites in this city were hit in the
attack
we travel to one a house in a
residential neighborhood
shattered israel's never before had to
deal with as much rocket fire
as they've seen over the past seven days
the israeli military
say the unprecedented tempo of the
rocket fire is very difficult to handle
one of the rockets that got past their
air defense system hit this house
there were three members of one family
inside they're too shaken to appear on
camera
but they told me that the rocket went
through the roof while the three of them
were sheltering in a safe room
no one was injured but they're clearly
very frightened
a couple of miles away a synagogue was
also struck
again no one hurt fear not so easily
washed away
rocket's not the only threat a man rams
into a police checkpoint
at a neighborhood in east jerusalem shot
dead
fury at a jewish legal attempt to evict
palestinians from sheikhshara
was one of the sparks to ignite this
crisis
hamas's leader even name-checking the
area in a speech warning israel's prime
minister
not to play with fire benjamin netanyahu
not backing down
our campaign against the terrorist
organizations is continuing with full
force we make hamas pay a very high
price for their intolerable aggression
mounting devastation in gaza and rocket
fire on israel underlining the need for
urgent diplomacy to broker a ceasefire
until then the pain grows debra haynes
sky news ashkelon